le témoin du jour je sais que vous
attendez tous les soirs l'invité du soir
et ce soir c'est un grand sportif c'est
Jérôme Thomas double médaillée olympique
de boxe qui va nous témoigner de sa
descente aux enfers on va revenir avec
lui là-dessus vous allez voir son
histoire est incroyable vraiment Gill
c'est fou regardez juste pour que vous
rappeliez bien de de de Jérôme Thomas
regardez Jérôme Thomas en plein combat
aux Jeux Olympiques regardez c'était lui
c'est lui et à chaque intervention de
l'arbitre le chronomètre est arrêté mais
les secondes desfil à une vitesse la
droite encore 3
secondes 13 points 13 points c'est
mission impossible Mission Impossible
porté par tout une les coups sont donés
dans les gants il y en a quelquesuns un
ou deux qui sont passés à travers mais
pas suffisamment net et on a quand même
donné deux touches au cubain
bon il a pas que ça évidemment faut pas
non il y a le talent il y a le talent de
l'adversaire qui est exceptionnel il est
tombé sur vraiment merci Jérôme Thomas
d'être avec nous c'est vous êtes un
énorme sportif double médaill olympique
boxeur de talent voilà je vous ai suis
des années j'adore en plus le personnage
que vous êtes euh alors c'est vrai que
quand on voit votre parcours on se dit
lui bah c'est une succès story
incroyable double médaille olympique
vous avez quel âge aujourd'hui je vais
avoir 45 ans samedi exactement ben on
viendra l'anniversaire et vous avez
après après donc tous ces succès
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé je sais que
vous avvez vous avez eu des problèmes
d'alcool c'est ça c'est ça en fait je
vais dire un mot c'est éphémère ou en
fait je sais moi j'ai toujours voulu
être connu àir de la reconnaissance et
je me disais is les star réalité c'est
c'est éphémère en fait tu sors d'une
téléréalité moi maintenant mais moi je
vous parle de il y a 24 ans en arrière
moi j'ai fait ma première médaille
olympique j'étais pas préparé à même si
je voulais l'être connu et ensuite j'ai
enchaîné j'étais champion du monde
j'étais vicechampion olympique et
j'étais pris dans le le
roulement de la fête de la nuit de
gagner de l'argent et malus gagn
beaucoup vous avez gagné beaucoup
d'argent ouais j'ai gagné beaucoup
d'argent ouais je c'est parce qu'on se
rend pas compte pour un un un combat
comme un championnat du monde on touche
combien non après il y a les amateurs il
a les pros bien sûr c'est ça oui moi
j'étais amateur donc ou voilà moi je je
faisais à l'époque en plus la prcription
je peux en parler je faenais je faisais
10000 € par par an par mois par mois
ouais donc faut gagner bien V c'est pour
ça que je jamais passé professionnel
d'accord voilà j'étais civil de la
défense j'étais sponsor paradidas la
ville de Saint-Quentin où j'habite la
région le département enfin tout ça
réuni donc vous viviez très bien voilà
euh malheureusement vous avez commencé à
boire c'est quoi c'est lors de soirées
que vous avez commencé à boire c'est
quoi c'est cétait à 16 ans ma première
soirée avec les grands comme j'appelle
ça les seniors ouais on était en Talasso
à Saint-Jean de Luse on est sorti parce
qu'on on travaillait beaucoup et puis
j'ai fait comme les grand j'ai voulu
essayer je me rappellerai toujours toute
ma vie parce que j'ai jamais rebu cet
alcool c'était de du alors justement
mais après quand on vient un grand
sportif vous Contin vous avez continué à
boire non en fait le l'alcool c'est
festif ouais c'est 3 semaines tu
t'entraînes 3 4 jours tu fais la
compétition tu gagnes tu perds tu fais
toi d'accord et quoi vous étiez déchiré
tu te la colles quoi tu puis tu manges
tu reprends 3 4 kg parce qu'il faut
savoir que je boxais en 51 kg ouais donc
c'est pas un poids c'est une température
ouais ça et j'étais pas mouche ouais et
donc les régimes secs bah faut les faire
quoi
c'est les mauvaises fréquentations c'est
les sorties aussi c'est ça non je suis
voilà j'étais adulte je j'assume tout ce
que j'ai fait voilà quoi quand tu es
dans le dans dans dans le tourbillon
c'est c'est mort c'est c'est c'est
courant ce genre d'addiction et de
dérive dans le monde du du sport
professionnel ou pas apparemment
maintenant j'en fais partie les
entraîneurs ou les sportifs après leur
carrière font tous une petite dépression
on va dire et moi ça fait longtemps que
ça dure vous es ans vraiment quoi
dépression vous vous la malisez comment
ça m se malise comment votre dépression
c'est-àdire que vous arrivez pas je
pleure j'en veux à la terre entière
pourquoi vous envoyz quoi bah je sais
pas parce que j'ai tout gâché tout ce
que j'ai tout ce que j'ai construit je
l'ai gâché racontez-nous c'est quoi vous
aviez construit quoi bah une belle vie
quoi une belle maison sur les bords de
marnes une vie de famille même si j'ai
pas d'enfants euh vous étiez marié non
non non vous aviez une une compagne une
ami voilà qui et voilà j'ai tout je
pense que j'ai tout détruit
comment vous avez tout détruit parce que
quand on vous écoute au début de du
témoignage on se dit bon c'est un mec
qui faisait un peu la fête voilà qui
sentraînit puis quand il a fini ses
combatson il faisait la fête mais quand
vous dites j'ai tout détruit comment
vous avez tout détruit qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé parce que j'ai pas été
entouré j'étais j'étais un assisté de la
vie j'étais àp à l'époque
ouaisîn voilà tuasas tu as 16 ans tu as
mal tu as mal au cheveux bah tu vas chez
le coiffeur en face tu as mal au ventre
tu vas chez le médecin et après tu te
retrouves dans la vraie vie comme
j'appelle ça à payer des factures à
payer un loyer h et quand tu as de moins
en moins les moyens tu gagnes plus
d'argent voilà moi je suis fonctionnaire
à la ville de Saint-Quentin vous faites
quoi maintenant je suis ambassadeur des
Jeux Olympiques pour la ville faut que
je me déplace dans les collèges lycées
et vous gagnez combien vous maintenant
bah je suis je suis non on parle pas
d'argent j'aime pas ça d'accord mais
mais je je gagne voilà je suis
fonctionnaire donc voilà quoi c'est quoi
c'est 1700 €. alors qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui a fait qu'aujourd'hui vous
dites vous avez tout perdu c'est c'est
quoi votre rapport aux femmes parce que
je sais que non mon rapport aux femmes
c'est que moi je suis dans le c'est tout
ou rien c'est j'aime ou j'aime pas je
fais ou je fais pas voilà j'ai décidé de
venir là je viens là d'accord voyez
j'aurais pu faire demi-tour avec mon
frère j'aurais dit ramène-moi en fait
j'y vais pas je suis comme ça je suis je
je dois être bipolaire peut-être c'était
quoi vos addictions à part à part
l'alcool c'était que l'alcool alcool
alcool alcool matin midi soir ouais
matin midi soir déjà terrible je dormais
alcool je vivais alcool je mangeais pas
pour avoir assez de place pour boire ah
ouais ouais c'est TR ah j'étais à fond
ouais c'est je fais tout je fais rien je
bois ou je bois pas donc aujourd'hui je
bois plus c'est c'est c'est bon pour ma
santé'estce fait qu'estce qu' a fait que
vous vous avez arrêté j'étais
prêt pas eu un déclic un déclic voilà
j'aime ma famille j'aime ma copine que
j'appelle mon
assistante j'aime mes parents quoi j'ai
pas envie de partir avant lu faire
plaisir ouais de que vous l'appz votre
assistante non mais c'est un terme c'est
c'est notre notre code c'est le terme
par qu'elle l'IDE l' beaucoup je pense à
mettre beaucoup et puis voilà ouais
ouais on la laisse dans l'ombre
aujourd'hui vous avez pu mettre de
l'argent de côté ou pas du tout non
j'avais une maison à 475000 € ouais sur
les bords de Marne bah voilà quoi comme
qu'est-ce qu' a fait que vous avez dû la
vendre parce que j'ai une séparation
diff difficile et voilà quoi elle a
préféré racheter ma part en état de
dessus h d'accord et là là aujourd'hui
vous
ah de de l'argent de la maison il rest
surv il vous reste quoi de l'argent de
la maison ah rien ah c'est rien rien tu
préférer les voitures et boire c'est
vrai ah ouais oua vraiment quoi les
voitures vous faisiez vous faisiez
plaisir les voitures ça les voitures
vous faisiez plaisir mais c'est un
délire je je me gratifie quoi là je suis
là je me gratifie je suis content je
vois plus tu m'invites bouou c'est ça
bah ouais non mais c'est fou parce que
c'est vrai que c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est drôle de enin c'est c'est c'est
intéressant d'entendre le témoignage
de Jérôme parce que c'est c'est fou
parce que moi je voilà on vous connaît
tous et c'est vrai que nous dans notre
tête on se dit et je suis sûr que les
téléspectateurs c'est pareil eux ils ont
une vie de fou c'est incroyable ils
doivent prendre beaucoup d'argent et ils
doivent être et aujourd'hui toi tu as la
vie de tu as la vie de voilà tu as une
vie non mais je suis voilà je sais que
vous avez reçu voilà je suis pas dehors
j'ai un
toit j'ai un boulot j'ai maintenant j'ai
une stabilité j'avais un problème c'est
l'alcool ouais et voilà quand c'est une
maladie hein c'est une maladie chronique
ça ne se so pas ouais ça se guérit pas
c'est veut dire que demain je peux
rechuter ah vraiment vous en avez
conscience bah il faut être pourquoi
j'ai réussi dans le sport parce que je
suis objectif je suis entier je me
remets en question je sais pourquoi je
gagne je sais pourquoi je perds ouais je
sais pourquoi mon mon boss il est gentil
avec moi ou pas mais aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous essayez d'éviter complètement
de voir des gens qui boient à côté de
vous sortir non ah du tout même quand il
y a des gens qui boivent à côté de vous
même quand vous allez faire vous ça vous
fait rien même déçu que dans la loge il
y a pas de champagne non c'est vrai il y
a pas d'alcool juste pour pas le boire
ouais juste pour dire à mon frère tu as
vu c'est de la merde ça et vous dites
que si vous rebuvez vous mourrez non
mais ça c'est ça c'est une image c'est
il y a pas de médicaments qui font que
tu bois tu vas mourir enfin ça serait
trop bien et trop facile ouais si je
rebois ça veut dire que je sais que
c'est la fin pour moi on pourra je
pourrais pas me relever une deuxième
fois vous vous avez peur cannibau je
serai mort vous avez peur de reboire
ouais non je non non j'ai peur de la vie
surtout j'ai peur de demain déjà et de
reboire non non non ça c'est dans ma
tête c'est une conviction vot papa votre
papa vous dites que votre papa il est
parti parce qu'il était alcoolique que
vous avez dit il était alcoolique il
était sous titel il vivait à Nice on l'a
retrouvé devant sa chambre d'hôtel avec
des
bleus et j'avais plus trop de nouvelles
parce que quand il m'appelit c'était
tout pour demander de l'argent un moment
je lui dit stop prendre mes nouvelles
d'abord et on l'a retrouvé comme ça
après on a fait une autopsie on l'a
remonté chez nous dans le Nord à
Saint-Quentin et finalement il avait le
cancer du
pouon c'est ça qui vous a marqué aussi
peut-être je sais pas non moi je suis un
je suis un je suis un effronté enfin je
suis handicapé moi déjà j'ai le syndrome
de polande c'est une maladie rare je
serai une femme j'aurais qu'un sein j'ai
qu'un PEC là d'accord et je suis n
qu'une main une main de canard qui était
collé on m'a opéré C fois voilà champion
de boxe j'étais voilà je je suis pas il
y a je suis voilà je suis dans les
valides non mais votre histoire est
folle pour ça c'est vraiment c'est une
histoire incroyable je vais écrire un
livre un deuxième parce que j'en ai déjà
fait un c'est vra que son histoire est
folle c'est vrai que vous êtes handicapé
ça pas c'est vrai et il est champion
champion de
boxe je sais que vous avez
financièrement vous avez pris des
crédits à la consommation parce que vous
avez déclaré
aussi ça vous avez 30000 € de dette àu
prè c'est la facilité voilà engrenage
c'est ça 30000 € de dette c'est comme ça
c'est c'est le prix à payer pour mes
conneries c'est quoi vos conneries
d'avoir acheté des trucs qui me serv à
rien c'est quoi ces
trucs des conneries des quoi dites-moi
de dire il y aucune honte pas des
perroquets des voilà quoi vous avez fait
un crédit pour acheter un perroquet
ch à quel moment vous dites je vais
faire un crédit pour faire pour acheter
un perroquet c'est génial ça c'est la
maladie du malaimé c'est vous dit je un
les gens ah ouais un perroquet combien
ça coûte un perroquet ch le Haruna il
m'a coûté 2008 et le
africain C à BAMO et puis voilà quoi le
gris du gabon c'est 2005
vous aviez pas l'argent pour acheter un
perroqu vous avez ach pour les anim
ouais je tricha un peu sur mes revenus
de salaire on va dire ah ouais auprès de
qui bah de
quoi même la banque la banque prête
ouais et vous avez acheté quoi comme
truc
fou non c'est bon franchement maintenant
c'est ça qui est intéressant aussi parce
que je pense que ce que vous allez dire
ça va parler à beaucoup de monde qui
nous regarde ils vont se dire on va pas
faire les les mêmes bêtises parce que
vous en par vous en parlez très bien et
en fait
vous vous on voit que vous avez
complètement conscience que vous avez
déconné ça moi j'aime bien quand vous
dites mais con
ou mais c'est hyper important pour les
gens qui nousent aujourd'hui direct
parce que comme vous l'avez dit l'alcool
c'est une maladie c'est une addiction
très très c'est très difficile de s'en
sortir et aujourd'hui moi je suis
heureux de vous voir comme ça et d'en
parler comme ça avec autant de
détachement parce que je vous trouve
détaché et c'est vrai que quand vous
dites voilà des conneries que j'ai fait
j'ai acheté un perroquet c'est vrai
qu'on a envie de savoir vous avez acheté
quoi c'est
quoi cinéma des conneries non non non
pas ça je non c'est des voyages des
déplacements justement par rapport à mon
addiction j'ai pas de voiture moi ouis
parce que j'ai pas envie de donner du
danger aux gens ouis escrintter
quelqu'un ou tuer une famille d'accord
donc je me suis dit j'ai pas de voiture
soit je prends le taxi soit on m'emmène
donc quand je fréquentais du du côté de
Bordeaux ou quoi ah je lou une voiture
la plus belle qui soit quoi et pu ah
ouais quoi non c'est pas des trucs de
ouf mais genre je sais pas 3008 non mais
non pas les discret français quoi ouais
citroëne c'est quoi c'est c'est vous
aviez c'est c'est les les femmes aussi
qui vous ont fait faire des dépenses des
trucs ou pas du tout non mais j'aime
faire plaisir ah ouais j' faisz plaisir
quoi tous vos potes et tout bah je
rinçais tout le monde c'est clair j'aime
pas faire la on entend souvent ça chez
les sportifs aussirai on entend il
rincit tout le monde voilà c'était ça
vous aussi après quand vous étiez bah
quand tu es connu tu as tu as les passes
tu rentres partout ouais voilà tu il y a
la parité mais ça existe pas quand tu es
connu ouais non tu as pas besoin de Nana
tu as 10 mecs tu res exactement tu mets
des bouteilles ah ouais la raison c'est
vrai vous faisiez des soirées quoi 2000
€ 1000 € 1000 € Mo je sais pas j'avais
pas une notion de l'argent ah ouais
vraiment met la carte et puis voilà quoi
ah ouais et donc vous rinciiez tout le
monde c'était et le problème c'est j'ai
continué de
vivre comme si je gagnais encore cet
argent exactement comme si vous gagnez
encore 10000 € mais SF que gagne 1008
par le banquier je lui dis fais-moi une
black ou une gold il me dit attention
monsieur Thomas ouais elle dit jamais
non ouais c'est vrai et notamment elle a
jamais dit non ah bah arriv à 12 m'a
appelé il m'a dit Monsieur Thomas vous
aurez pas fait voler vre4 non je dis
fallait dire oui c'est non mais c'est
qui l'
bouffé moi j'aimerais savoir aussi votre
rapport parce que vous êtes une énorme
star voilà moi qui suis fan de box si si
bah si plus gros champions français je
te le dis tu un des plus gros champions
français je connais bien la box le sais
est aussi d'accord avec
moi as senti comment comment c'est c'est
quoi le le changement avec tous les gens
par que tu dois avoir plein de gens
autour de toi tu devis avoir tous les
mecs qui te qui te pass la pomade ouais
jeis lucide en fait plus alors déjà pas
grand mond de m'intéresser avec la
lucidité il y a encore moins de monde
qui m'intéresse et mais tu as senti que
les mecs voilà les mecs qui étaient
derrière toi tu as senti que tu avais
beaucoup beaucoup de monde autour de toi
et qu'après beaucoup
moins c'est clair quand tu maintenant tu
vas moi il faut que je vois du monde
parce que je suis vachement dans la
solitude mais il faut que je vois du
monde je suis seul mais avec du monde
ouais donc je faut faut que je sorte si
je reste chez moi je suis pas bien ouais
donc bah tu bois un diabol fraise
t'intéresse déjà Mo de monde ah ouais
donc tu vite tu le tri en fait ouais
c'est ça et même les mecs que tu rinces
plus tout ça tu les vois plus tous les
mecs que tu rinçais à l'époque tu les
vois toujours ou pas ah mais moi c'est
j'ai j'avais pas d'amis j'en ai encore
moins ah vraiment ouais tu que tu
entouré de qui aujourd'hui mon
assistante et puis mes frères qui qui
m'ont qui m'ont tendu la main qui m'ont
sauvé la vie surtout c'est vrai ouais
tes frères ils étaient là quand quand ça
cartonnait pour toi ouais ouais ouais
ils ont toujours été là et derrière ils
ont vu est-ce qu' un moment il y a un de
tes frères ou quelqu'un de ta famille ou
un de tes proches qui t'a dit Jérôme je
crois tu es en train de partir en
cacahuète et que tu vas dans ils ont
jamais osé de me le dire parce que sinon
je me braque ouais c'est ça et je les
vois plus ouais tu es comme moi toi h
ouais je me braque vite donc je me
braquais quoi et puis un jour je j'ai
appelais j'ai dit il faut venir là ah
ouais tu as eu parce que tu es es
extrêmement fier tu as eu tu as eu le tu
t'es dit là je peux plus parce que si je
les appelle pas ouis j'étais au bout
j'étais au bout des choses tu leur as
dit quoi tu les as appelé ah j'ai dit
faut venir ils t'ont dit il faut venir
ils sont arrivés tout de suite ils m'ont
vidé le frigo mon petit frère qui a
infirmier m'a dit demain matin je vais
faire une prise de sang ouais il est
venu il m'a enfermé chez moi
ensuite il a revenu à 11h il avait déjà
il fallait peut-être 6 à 8 mois
d'attente il m'a dit voilà je t'ai pris
un rendez-vous est-ce que tu veux y
aller j'ai dit oui et la femme m'a
tellement mis en confiance que moi je me
suis fait entre guillemets interné par
mon par mon c'est moi c'est mon souhait
c'est pas mes frères et je dit faut que
je me soigne tuétais pascte au jeu aussi
ouais mais ça c'est le poker mais c'est
tout le monde que tu me dis pas tout là
beaucoup là mais sin ça va être long il
y aura plus assez de temps non mais
poker c'est pas tout le mondeas to aussi
tuim jou poker tu ouais parce que je je
suis Velard je suis comme j'étais dans
la boxe ouais j'ai ce vis qui fait que
j'aime les choses qui pe que je peux pas
limite toucher tu préfères ta vie
d'avant ou ta vie de maintenant je sais
pas là maintenant que je suis lucite je
suis triste quoi je suis tu es triste
j'ai plus l'alcool pour m'alcooliser
pour oublier que je suis triste
maintenant tuas maintenant tu as une
fiancée tu as des frères qui t'entourent
tu as un métier pourquoi tu es triste
comme ça je sais pas j'ai toujours été
triste même quand tu étais champion du
monde
ouais ça vous savez il y a pas longtemps
j'ai
contacté
un vendre mes médailles parce que dég
quoi c'esti sérieux tu as appelé
quelqu'un pour vendre tes médailles
dégoû pourquoi ça te dégoûte c'est
incroyable pas c'est comme si j'étais au
chômage et je regardais mon mon
baccalauréat sur le mur encadré j'ai le
même sentiment tu veux plus voir ces
médailles tu veux plus voir ces images
de toi quand tu étais champion j'ai plus
rien de chez moi chez moi j'ai plus rien
des jeux j'ai tout donné tout mais tu en
es pas fier quand même de d'avoir été
champion du monde tu en es fier normal
c'était monob non c'est pas normal la
boxe ça vous plaît plus normal vous
regardez plus les combats tout ça ça
vous intéresse plus non non très peu
parce que j'ai encore mon frère qui boxe
ouais mais non ça m'intéresse pas je
suis Jérôme c'est c'est incroyable ton
témoignage vraiment je suis très content
de t'avoir rencontré en tout cas
incroyable il faut vraiment faut pas que
tu sois TR tu es un immense champion il
y a beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui sont
fers de toi et de ce que tu as amené à
la France et donc vraiment tu te rends
pas compte je pense que tu minimises
beaucoup ce que tu as fait et quand tu
dis boxer c'est mon métier on peut boxer
il y a plein de boxeurs qui sont pas
champions du monde je te dis il y en a
moins qui sont en a moins qui sont
champions du monde que des mecs qui son
et surtout des des Français il y a y en
a peu et tu es tu es un immense champion
je te le dis au contraire pour moi toi
tu dois que profiter de la vie et te
dire voilà ce que j'ai fait c'est
incroyable et aujourd'hui je faux
profiter
vraiment es un mec exceptionnel voilà
mercior merci mer
d'AV